I brought you a gift first of all you're
invited any time you bring alcohol so
wait what is this villa-lobos is my new
tequila with John Varvatos started about
two and a half years ago we started the
process of working with Stoli group to
develop our own tequila and actually try
I know it's like you know this show airs
at like 9:00 a.m. and I'm looking at you
no no but yeah I don't want to be rude
let's do it Nick let's do it
Congrats to my mama raised to polite
young lady I will drink your tequila
sorry enough I mean I guess we're
rationing it's fine that is good it's so
smooth I was a little nervous because
usually I do like a lot I mean I don't
drink everybody know I do usually like
salt and lime that's really smooth yeah
we're excited about it so we just
launched this one on the East Coast and
the rest of the country is kind of
starting now but then we have Reposado
and then yeah how is well it's coming
out I'm into it okay so we're so let's
celebrate real quick you want another
one okay find out well um let's
celebrate and drink to your first season
of The Voice you don't have to a better
opportunity I'm trying to be kind I just
want to celebrate the fact they're gonna
be on The Voice I'm gonna kick your tail
oh that's not true anything
but for that I'm not gonna clap for that
I used to clap for that man it has been
a good little friendly competition so
far though it has we've you know eight
on the blinds which has been really fun
my first ever assembled a good team
I feel confident about it and we like a
lot of the same sound yes I didn't
expect that I know John and I would go
head to head but now II I knew it I knew
it and they the guys were talking I was
like he's gonna be I'm gonna have to
battle Nick freakin Jonas like what I'm
not gonna win they're like a mom like so
not cool compared to you like what I
will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this